stairs to chris haynes damien lillard
you guys got it to this point you're in
the play-in game
i've noticed the next step to the
playoffs but this game right here
talk about how agonizing it was for you
guys down the stretch
i mean i since we've been in a bubble
i've been watching every single game i
could you know whenever we're not
practicing or playing i'm in a room
watching games or in our meeting room
watching games
and i caught a lot of their games and
coming in i was like who who's going to
be on 18
you know what what's going to happen
with their team
because i saw how many guys didn't come
and once i saw him play
i knew i knew what we was coming into
tonight i've seen like three of their
games
um and i knew it was gonna be this type
of game you know we weren't gonna come
in here and just
get them out of there you know they they
play with a lot of effort they play
together they believe
um and karen's levert is cold
so we came out here and earned another
win you know i think uh it feels better
going into the playing game knowing that
our eight games we had to work for so we
deserve to be where we're going
what was going through your mind when
karis levert had an isil situation to
possibly win the game
i mean we came into the game saying you
know they they like to penetrate and
kick out for a lot of threes and if we
limit the threes then we gonna have a
good chance to win
but like i said man he's a he's a great
player so he's going to find a way to
to be effective and he got into the
paint a lot he lived in the paint he
finished he made tough shots
he was crafty he was creative all night
but once i saw cj sit down and keep him
out the paint and make him settle for a
tougher shot
at that point i was like we got a good
chance you know because he hasn't had to
take a lot of those shots off the bounce
moving that fast all night so it was
just let's go get the rebound mellow
crashed in
came up with it and we finished the game
with a stop brooklyn
started to trap you even before you
reached half court
you went and took a shot near the logo
what was why why why would you take that
shot at that point
at that junction i mean our season is on
the line and you know i
you know maybe two and a half three and
a half minutes went by where
i was just trying to make the right play
you know two guys was coming to me and i
was just outletting it to the first guy
i saw so we could attack him and have an
advantage
and then it got to the point where i was
like i'm not gonna i'm not gonna sleep
well tonight knowing that i just
was passive and made the right place so
each time i saw it look i don't care how
far it was or
if somebody was close to me if i had a
sniff i was raising up and shooting it
and that's
that's why i shot that one well dan good
luck saturday three seconds
damn at a double-double it's the 11th
time this season that he's had a
40-point game
well we finish off with a beauty and now
they've got a great one coming up the
play-in game memphis in portland on
saturday